so this is a defining moment for europe
and
it is a moment where we see that putin's
war
is also a question
of the resilience of democracies
at this summit we will rethink
european defense with strong
capabilities
we will rethink energy
we have to get rid of the dependency of
russian fossil fuels and for that we
need
massive investment in renewables this is
also a strategic investment in our
security and our independence it creates
jobs at home and it is homegrown we're
independent
and we will also certainly discuss
um ukraine as part of as our
of our european family
we want a free and democratic ukraine
with whom we share a common destiny
[Music]
and it's indeed also a test of the
resilience of our democracies this is
why we do
we think at this summit our european
defense with strong capabilities
we will rethink energy because we have
to get rid of the dependencies of
russian fossil fuel with massive
investment
in renewables because these renewables
give us as a strategic investment
independence and security and of course
we will discuss the
ukraine as part of our european family
we want a free and democratic ukraine
with whom we share a common destiny
[Music]